welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and if you've
been keeping up to date with the channel
and you'll know that yesterday I
reported on a huge leak on the upcoming
phase 5 & 6 light of the MCU as well as
where the universe will be heading in
the future the leaks reported by
industry insider TiVo and earth all of
the big changes in the MCU including its
new villain and all of the casting news
that could be coming our way
the link to that video will be popping
up right now so if you want to learn
everything that was said in the report
then make sure you click it at the top
but this video I just want to focus
purely on one key part of the news which
is that the next Avengers film will be
called Secret Wars and it will
drastically change the landscape of the
film franchise this is full spoilers
ahead and wilds leaks like this should
be taken with a grain of salt there's a
lot that lines up here and seems like a
natural progression for the universe
either way there are potentially huge
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything about the upcoming films ruined
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into my breakdown of
the Avengers Secret Wars leaks
okay so first up TiVo said that the next
big Avengers endgame level event will be
Secret Wars which will be built up to in
phases 4 5 & 6 with the new phases only
lasting for about two years this means
that Marvel are kind of steam rolling
ahead with this and that we will be
getting the huge crossover event in six
years which is almost half the time that
it took to get the infinity Wars saga
wrapped up for those who don't know
Secret Wars is actually a relatively new
comic book story that was only released
in 2015
whilst it does have the same name as the
1984 comic it's a completely different
entity and it actually changed the
Marvel Universe in several ways and its
core it was pretty much about Marvel
wiping the slate clean and involved the
destruction of a vast amount of
alternate timelines such as Ultimate
Marvel Age of Apocalypse House of M and
many more it eventually led to a new
earth being form that was made
all the shared parts of the timelines
which was known as battle world
this is interesting because Tebow also
name-drop battle world in the leaks and
said that after the events of secret
wars that the Marvel Universe would be
split into several sectors in an almost
game of thrones like mana with there
being several different territories
spread across the world the leaks said
that dr. doom would end up controlling
Europe after having been introduced in
the fantastic four movies and that the
Mandarin would also control Asia the
Mandarin is of course already confirmed
as the new big bad of the shang-chi film
so if he survives at the end of that
movie then I definitely think I'll add a
lot of weight to this rumor Red Skull is
reportedly returning and the villain
will rule over America and have u.s.
agent as its henchman u.s. agent is
supposedly going to make his debut in
the Falcon and Winter Soldier show and
will be the enemy to the two titular
characters who are still out Lord after
the events of Civil War u.s. agent is a
government-appointed Captain America and
if the rumors are correct and he'll be
going head-to-head with Falcon for the
mantle throughout the Disney Plus series
now apparently at Red Skull side he will
help to keep order in the US before
betraying him further down the line to
join the good guys the MCU hasn't really
set up that many alternative universes
at the moment so Secret Wars will likely
be similar to age of Ultron where they
adapt minor elements but stick to the
status quo on the whole however if they
are dealing with alternate timelines
that we can't see that these have been
slowly getting introduced to the MCU an
endgame far from home and of course the
upcoming Doctor Strange film this could
potentially show the full breadth of the
multiverse and it would also allow
mutants to come into the main timeline
only to be stuck there due to their
universe being wiped out by secret wars
scott derrickson who is directing Doctor
Strange also posted a multiverse image
to Twitter recently and this could also
be teasing House of M which would of
course add more way to the Secret Wars
Theory youtuber wars' to you sent me
this this morning and we both think it
could be confirmation of House of M
being alluded to down the line the
multiverse of madness could potentially
bring forth hundreds of different
timelines and the movie could leave this
open to being dealt with fully in the
future Avengers films I have no doubt
that Doctor Strange will become a member
of
Benji's team so it makes sense that
these two films could tie together the
secret wars storyline itself ends in a
battle between Doctor Doom and the Black
Panther the latter of which has the
Infinity Gauntlet
this is interesting as the Infinity
stones were returned to their own times
in the MCU and the gauntlet has also
been replicated so with black panther
now being a prominent character this
could definitely be a final battle after
the world is pretty much in roon doom
surrenders his powers and the earth is
healed into a world known as earth prime
which most notably sees Miles Morales
joining it this would definitely be huge
for the MCU and due to the success of
into the spider-verse I can actually see
Marvel wishing to bring him to the big
screen in the live-action film at the
end of the comic dr. doom is also
revealed to be no longer disfigured at
the end of the storyline so if he is
introduced in the Fantastic Four film as
the main film then the Avengers movie
could potentially be the end of his arc
with the character getting Redemption by
its clothes whilst the other leaks from
Tebow said that Galactus would to be
joining the MCU is one of the next big
villains
I actually think Marvel will save him
more for the cosmic side of the MCU
before slowly introducing him to the
earth characters similar to how an ass
was weaved through guardians of the
galaxy before becoming such a big force
in the Infinity soccer overall I'm
really excited for the direction of the
Marvel Universe is heading in and if
this all comes true then I can
definitely see it being a huge event
that massively shakes up the MCU
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on these leaks and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up as
it massively helps the channel out if
you want to hear all of the spoilers
that tebow reported on then make sure
you check out my full breakdown of this
entire report which will be linked at
the end in it I go over all of the
rumors so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to come talk to me about movies TV shows
games and comic books then you can
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey
it's the best way to get in touch with
me and it's the perfect place to suggest
new videos and content so hopefully I
see you over there after this also just
want to let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of John wick 3 on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is to like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
Avengers secret wars in the
comment section below the one will be
chosen at random on September the 10th
and the blue arrow be shipped out from
then to ever get surprise so best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you